Voy a escribir un número por aquí y quiero
que pienses en qué valor representa cada
uno de los dígitos de este número. De hecho,
déjame seleccionar este 2 de aquí, ¿qué valor
representa?, ¿representa sólo 2 o algo diferente
a sólo 2? Pausa el video y piénsalo. Bien,
vamos a pensarlo juntos. Empecemos con el 7. El 7
está en el lugar de las unidades, así que este 7
representa 7 unidades, que por supuesto sólo es 7,
así que no hay nada sorprendente por aquí. Podemos
pasar al lugar de las decenas, así que este 1
no sólo representa 1, representa una decena,
otra forma de pensarlo es que representa 10. Muy
bien, mientras que el 2 que se encuentra justo
aquí está en el lugar de las centenas, por lo
tanto no sólo representa 2, representa 2 centenas,
o podemos escribir que representa el valor
de 200. El número que tenemos aquí es 217,
y el 2 representa 2 centenas o 200. Entonces,
déjame hacerte una pregunta ligeramente distinta.
Vamos a escribir tres números que intencionalmente
no voy a decir en voz alta: tenemos este número,
este otro número y este otro número, y lo que
quiero que hagas es que pauses el video y que
me digas en cuál de estos tres números el
7 representa 70. Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bien, vamos a trabajar juntos. Empecemos con el
número de arriba. En este número, el 7 está en el
lugar de las unidades, así que este 7 representa
7 unidades que sigue siendo 7, por lo tanto, este
7 no representa 70. En el siguiente escenario,
el 2 está en el lugar de las unidades y podemos
ver que el 7 está en el lugar de las decenas, así
que este 7 representa 7 decenas, y 7 decenas es lo
mismo que 70, así que, de hecho, en esta segunda
situación, el 7 representa 70. Este número es 572:
el 7 representa 70. Y, por último, veamos este
tercer número: bueno, aquí el 7 no está en el
lugar de las unidades ni en el de las decenas,
está en el lugar de las centenas, así que este
7 representa 7 centenas o 700, lo cual tiene
sentido, ya que este número de aquí es 705.